[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like 8 p.m. 9 p.m. so we just landed in
Paris isaacfitz
succeeded in getting me sick because I
barely have a voice my sore throat is
like very sore I survived for now we
just don't air doesn't no one that has a
stronger immune system than you
you always get sick no because I've been
I've been really into making bone broth
at home recently
instead of doing a lot of like whole was
that holistic medicine I guess like
natural foods no so I'm super healthy
right I mean I was drinking the bone
broth too but I guess not enough but
anyway we're here very exhausting as you
can cover it but we're about to go eat
so we get to enjoy tonight an entire day
tomorrow which will be our anniversary
[Music]
another one and then the next day we
leave tomorrow itself should be a fun
trip our 21 day voyage is finally
beginning this is our big anniversary
trip that we've been planning for half a
year now
we were bit we've been married for over
a year now so we decided to come back to
France that's our first stop to enjoy
the actual anniversary day here in Paris
just because we got married here and
then from here we're gonna fly over to
Morocco and spend some time in Morocco
and explore Africa first trip ever on
that continent so I'm super excited
about Morocco and after that we're gonna
swing over to London and have a nice
little closer in London before heading
back to the u.s. super ready to get it
started
I know it is it like the lease in
through the end I think I probably have
ever been in a blog but it's just I'm
trying not to strain my my voice too
much but I really am excited he that the
Anniversary happy Anniversary baby
yay one-year married I'm putting my
husband for a whole year now I'm not
crazy
have you gotten used to being husband or
wife well I think I brought you to call
you my husband but every time I think
about it I can't get this every time you
think about it I'm like whoa my husband
crazy like that part I haven't gotten
over I guess I don't think I ever will
because it's kind of similar to me being
a mom sometimes like I have to tell
myself like whoa I'm the mom that's
crazy that's my kid over there I don't
know I've never really like set in fully
I don't know maybe this is nothing I
know what you mean I don't like the idea
of being a grown-up - yeah to me it's
like man 30 years old and full like I'm
a full fledge rowing up now yeah man I
know paying my bills and stuff but then
it's a part of me that still thinks I'm
a boy cute
that's a husband's job right there all
right so we we have a really really late
start today it is uh if it's one o'clock
her still in the hotel your new wake up
to have breakfast though the reason why
it's so late though because all last
night we kept tossing and turning
because we're a jet lag so I think we
woke up like you woke up like at 2:00
a.m. to like four or seven or something
I don't know but like I kept waking up
throughout the whole night to it oh my
god force yourself to go to sleep cuz
I'm actually say nothing we'd be tired
by now like all day during the day so I
swear I was laying in bed
my eyes closed for like the whole hour
and I couldn't go to sleep but at least
you feel better though your voice is
better I think I have let a little less
phlegm today so hopefully anytime we get
to Morocco it I'll be even better you
know it's kind of cool we have the same
anniversary as the Royals now like
hariom and they copy us I don't
recognize I think you kind of like think
about everything like my last name is
means from royalty and then yeah Del Rio
and then the fact that we got married on
this day which is the day that they're
getting married or a year ago we got
married so we got shared an anniversary
with them like Megan's American that's
pretty cool oh yeah we're gonna land in
London before we head back to LA before
we go to Croatia now we have a lot of
traveling to do oh that's right I didn't
tell him about the Croatia trip yet
morph element on Croatia we found out
about that trip after we planned this
trip and that's why we're flying back to
LA before going to Croatia because it
would just make so much more sense to
stay on this side of the world good to
go all the way back over there but then
the whole flight thing is just way too
complicated so we're like we'll just
keep the flights we have and deal with
the traveling so we ended up upgrading
to business to like spoil ourselves a
little bit their anniversary trip that's
why we're not canceling the flight yeah
I want to cancel on a business wipe so
now we're gonna get our day started
we're gonna first head over to the
Eiffel Tower to get some updated photos
ya know that we're 2020 public guided
anniversary
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
are we looking for fine nice coat I
think I feel like people that have these
really nice like long time either
cardigans or something that's in between
a cardigan and a coat I don't know it's
called but a lot of people wearing those
like oh I want one I'm trying to see
like do they have a clearance section
you come all the different section
[Music]
getting ready for the new season
we got a so we're at expeller you have
to let me get which they have nothing
but very fancy designers I want to buy
here cause I'm not rich
[Music]
we have got a lot of we met up so now
we're at the Luxembourg Gardens cuz
Casey and I wanted to check it out we've
never never been here
it's really beautiful a lot of people to
shopping on a Spanish tour to figure out
what's going on with the statue Sammy
told me she's like this every time I
come I always forget the story like she
looks it up and then she forgets it so
she was about to look it up again but I
totally understand and so I walk over
and do the same like very little yeah
[Music]
really bad the hotel friend
so now it
you're wearing a white shirt under want
to take the blue shirt off
are you know
[Music]
here myself in a bowl
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh struggling with the death
tossing and turning China
ourselves too
Isaac Isaac all this oh yeah I think
this follows after that's why we will go
that's right yeah I think Alden
which movies very inappropriate I'm like
sorry you can't watch that and
but now we're on our way to the airport
because we're heading to Casablanca
it's actually kind of cool how we're
doing that you know the movie
we're zooming in this trip right now oh
and then Sam the pianist pianist my
cousin's name is Sam
there's so many connections for the
movie Casablanca looking forward to it
food got more stuff well that's a given
all right thank you all right I don't
know like when I heard him right on the
website because if we're doing this tour
thing right and when I heard about the
camel ride I was sold
yeah my cousin Blanca look at all the
white buildings don't hit the chandelier
coming after me
[Music]